allegedly deceptive practices by uber
reportedly prompted Apple's CEO to
threaten to pull the company from
Apple's App Store the extraordinary
episode is revealed in a New York Times
profile of uber CEO Travis kalanick it
says Apple CEO Tim Cook summoned cali
nick after learning uber broke apples
privacy guidelines neither uber nor
Apple commented on the meeting New York
Times technology reporter Mike Isaac
wrote the story he's in Washington good
morning Mike hey thanks for having me
it's extremely rare for the CEO of Apple
to call in another company for a
scolding what happened yeah so uber had
been essentially trying to implement a
technology solution to a large amount of
fraud that they had in their platform
the problem was a lot of those solutions
were tricky and obfuscate adapa land so
Tim Cook essentially wanted to make kind
of an example out of uber by calling in
travis kalanick and giving him a sort of
scolding in his office and saying knock
this off her we're going to pull you
from the App Store which would have
essentially tanked ubers business never
good to be called to the woodshed but
certainly not good to be called to the
woodshed so publicly what do you think
is the outcome of this conversation and
how do we know about it well I spent the
past three or four months reporting this
out and spoke to about 50 different
people over the who have known mr.
kalnick throughout his career in life
and so a number of those sources were
just sort of worried about ubers
willingness to push the boundaries of
what what is acceptable and what's
really ethical in business that said all
of mr. kalmyks tactics have really
worked you know uber is worth a close to
70 billion dollars so they haven't had
that much of a punishment except for a
pretty public PR crisis right now well
Mike the mantra is growth above all else
what does that say I mean the the tone
is set from the very top and and Travis
seems to you know really care about
growth a lot right now he's taking a
drubbing in public so we'll see if that
actually makes him change his leadership
stance which has always been aggressive
but
haven't seen any any indication there's
no indication at all that he's willing
to understand the problem he's in and he
understands that he's got to do
something well Charlie I think yeah to
be fair they said they are looking for a
chief operating officer right now
essentially a strong number 22 back
Travis up and and he has said publicly
he needs leadership help so some folks
are saying you know maybe this episode
actually broke through to to the boss
and then others are that I've spoken to
her kind of skeptical and and you know
they known the guy his whole career and
he seems to have a way of doing things
so we'll see if he's actually learned we
reached out to burr and they told us
this quote we do not track individual
users or their location if they've
deleted the app but they do collect
location data up to five minutes after
the trip ends are there still a number
of privacy concerns when it comes to
over yeah I think that's right a lot of
folks were pretty upset at uber 'he's
decision to essentially force you to
keep location tracking on after you had
closed your app and finish the trip now
like you said there's a five-minute
window and uber sort of maintains this
is to help gps and mapping settings but
still it's it's made some folks
uncomfortable but it's a trade off
essentially if you want to continue
using the app and and hopefully make it
better all right Mike Isaac we thank you
very much for joining us from Washington
this morning thank you